[Música]
ela sofre golos há mais um vídeo e hoje
vou fazer um rio do mar manevy
neste caso temos uma shot gun o contador
objetivo que diz para 6 balas
o ste antes de fazer alguns filmes como
armas nero livrar alguns efeitos
especiais que fazer tpao e curtiu a
última mas nada a ver oque uma versão
caseira mas para isso preciso de armas
suficientes então se comprar estas armas
e à medida que for comprar hoje e vou
fazendo vilsack para um canal
atualmente esta é primeira e pintada que
o tânio mas eu quero pintar diz que
antônio e acho que comprar depois agora
está foi a primeira vez que tem uma arma
então não ficou assim em tão tão grande
coisa e se vocês tiverem sugestões de
como eu posso fazer melhor
deixe nos comentários que eu possível
quando você já tentam ajudar em termos
de precisão está a maré é boa mas para
curtas e médias distâncias agora para
longas distâncias não é ser muito boa
porque a mira tem se uma coisa que meu
batata lhe à frente é muito grande é
aquela coisa não dá pra fazer uma linha
reta com o alvo então estarmos aqui é
boa para curtas e médias distâncias
se vocês quiserem fazer aquele efeito do
fumo que vocês viram no início é
bastante simples
você só tem por tal como na que é o
tambor rotativo e depois quando as balas
saírem vão tirar um pouco de pó para
fora e vai fazer aquele efeito de fuga
já estou aqui treinar algumas coisas que
podem fazer com esta arma para o vídeo
ao tentar fazer algo e com zumbis é
estaria muito engraçado fazer assim uma
personagem desistiu assim em todo mauzão
aqui eu sou sempre muito mauzões de tudo
o que as une né então de fazer uma
pessoa mais alegre a lutar contra os
homens para contrariar um caso essa
situação que vocês conseguem ver a parte
do tal costal falar antes para fazer
aquela efeito do fumo e agora eu vou
abrir a arma e individualizar as partes
por pintar e assim o foi final vai ficar
melhor do que pintar por cima usando um
pincel e é importante que você tirar
algumas fotografias da vida que forem de
montar a maneira que você estiver lá em
casa nos casar mas sim duas mas existem
aquelas bem complicadas então convencer
a fotos para depois consegui montar tudo
de volta entre vocês pintar é muito
importante usar a este tipo de máscara
saque contra quintas tem que ser mesmo
especial contra tintas e não aquelas
contra pó choque é porque este tem de
ser um muito mau e fazem mal para a
segunda até então muito importante você
se proteger e e combinava vocês fizerem
isto fora de casa que aí porque assim é
mais fácil já que eu fiz em casa porque
não tinha opção mas eu vou fazer uma
caixa especial com ventoinhas que vai
mandar os gases para fora
e então eu acho que fazer um vídeo para
vocês verem como eu vou fazer essa caixa
para ficar mais realista e uma tinta
preta plástica e fui sujando a volta das
peças é que acho que eu ter me indicado
pousar nesta situação depois limpa
usando um pano úmido e desta maneira a
quinta fica aonde ficar surge dado
momento nos armários para que a água
fica funcionar com mantas é muito
importante vocês pintar em suas peças no
lado de fora
deixe na parte interna como estava antes
e neste caso eu não tentei o tambor
porque vão passar as balas por lá então
se o pintar o atrito vai aumentar entre
a bala e o cano e assim vai diminuir a
distância seja o alcance da então eu
recomendo que também num pinto em um
tambor e para finalizar vocês têm que
colocar as peças todas como estavam
antes
e é muito importante que não sobra
nenhum parafuso ok
[Música]
hebron sol chegamos enfim espero que
vocês tenham gostado deste tipo de vídeo
se gostaram deixe nos comentários que eu
gosto sempre de saber a vossa opinião
que podem deixar tamanhos comentários
qual é aproximar maneira que vocês
gostariam de ver aqui no canal as mais
pedidas são aquelas que eu vou trazer e
profissional safin muito obrigada a ter
estilo eu espero que vocês tenham se
lenta novo e não esqueçam se vocês
querem algo tem que lutar por isso e não
ficar à espera neste caso crie uma arma
suja e tem mais não seja porque eu fiz
por isso até a próxima